thank you so much for joining us today
we're gonna be talking about kubernetes
engine infrastructure and
service-oriented monitoring with Equifax
my name is Roxana I'm a product manager
on Google cloud focused on cloud
monitoring and today my guest is gonna
be Vito he is a lead asari
at Equifax for the next 30 minutes we're
gonna be focusing on three main topics
we're gonna start by discussing SLO
monitoring principles we're gonna do Q&A
with people from Equifax to really
understand how Equifax has adopted
excellence and the digital
transformation journey that they are
undertaking and then at the end we're
gonna have a demo
Patrick witches are engineering the heat
on cloud monitoring it's gonna give us a
demo of how you can use a solos and SLO
monitoring to monitor our chicken feed
of micro sensors so let's start thinking
a little bit about what are the
principles behind a salon monitoring I
know probably many of you have heard
about us Alex and when we think about us
alone it feels like we are talking a lot
about numbers and targets and goals we
talk a lot about how many nights do we
have and how important it is to collect
these numbers of nights almost like
badges of honor we talk about how
important it is for us to have the best
reliability out there and a lot of
people really try to strive extensively
to reach that a hundred percent
reliability goal for basically every
single micro service that they own and
that's what I want us to start with from
the point of realizing that this
conversation is not about numbers it's
not about getting every single micro
service to its maximum availability
possible and it's a hundred percent it's
their own target to begin with and
surprisingly enough
even though this is such an incredible
engineering driven experience what we
were gonna talk about today is actually
language because what is more important
for us than anything else is to figure
out what is a common language that we
can give every single person within our
organization the ability to communicate
towards the same successful so let's
think about the business process you
start with a concept you end up building
requirements with your product team your
marketing team with your sales teams
you're not defining the goal and the
business goal for your product you start
engaging with your engineering teams and
build the development of that product
you start working and engaging later on
your operations teams and your
operations things wants to ensure that
what we built it's reliable and scalable
and it's performant and then you start
taking the product to market the problem
is the way that I told this story is
that it feels like this is setup
sequence that's and you have to
introduce all of these people into the
process one by one but what is important
for us is that we actually need to have
the business the development and the
operations team to collaborate together
on defining what does success look like
for the organization as a whole and when
we talk about success it has to be a
single metric that all of these things
and all of these people get behind these
metrics really need to reflect what the
end customer experience is all about we
need to think about the CJS how the end
user uses our product and we need to
ensure that we are building the right
measurement of that CJ and we make this
measurement understandable and available
to everyone in the organization so when
we talk about defining success s loz
gives us the ability to create a common
language
across business development and
operations to understand what is
important for the organization and how
to instrument this into trackable
metrics but because this is a common
language and it's a new language across
the org we're gonna have a few new terms
we're gonna need to get familiar
oscillate so these are the three core
terms of service oriented monitoring so
what is an SLI MSRI is a service level
indicator think about this as a metric
under threshold it is a measure of what
success looks or feels like an SLO is
the service level objective and the the
difference near think about the metric
that you build your SLI on and you
attach a goal to it so you have a
fraction of your successful interactions
that you're interested in let's say you
have a retail website and you care about
measuring customer happiness with your
checkout service you know that a lot of
your financial team is really
interesting to make sure that people can
check out and pay for the items that
they care about so we know that that is
a cornerstone of the experience we know
that we want the service to be available
but most importantly we don't want our
customers to be frustrated so here we're
gonna start thinking about how fast do
we want our users to experience the
stage and it could be a matter of
seconds so now we need to know how what
your share of customers should
experience this so maybe we'd have a
target where we can have a business goal
that at least 95 percent of all of our
customers have - over the checkout card
service and visualize the data and the
items in that other cart in less than
five seconds and that is the goal so as
you can notice we're not talking about
knives we are talking about the end
customer experience and that's a really
important
to make as we are thinking about how to
measure he and customer experience and
lost item here probably all of you are
already familiar with because an SLA is
the service level agreement and that
takes yes Li the metric attaches the
goal but then it has some consequences
around it so for example this is a
contract that you might make with your
external customers when you tell them
that we have an availability our product
will be available for this amount of
time under the constraints and if we
don't meet those requirements then we
will offer you refunds so a lot of
companies have implemented SFA's in
these contracts with their external
customers what we are trying to get them
to understand is we already have the
underlying under an SLA there is a
wrestle itself and these are really
powerful metrics that can transform the
organization and bring your business
your development in operations into a
single frame of mind so now that we have
this new language I think it's important
for us to see what is a great example of
how to take this language and put it
into practice and equifax has been an
incredible advocate within their own
company of adapting excellence and I am
extremely happy and privileged to have
today people join us he is an SRE lead
and Equifax and he's gonna tell us a
little bit about the SLO journey but
there so people please introduce
yourself tell us a little bit about your
role and tell us a little bit about the
equifax architecture thanks from Shonda
for having me it's been pleasure so
about my role I've been with Equifax 14
years
Equifax has been great up and started as
a developer 14 years back so did various
roles and then most recently I've been
working as a Sree for one of the
Alliance data fabric within
a little bit about Equifax Equifax is a
global company we are data analytics and
technology company we operate into 24
countries and the platform that I'm
responsible my day-to-day role as an SRE
is a enterprise data like pattern and
Equifax is on this digital
transformation journey and Google is our
platform of choice to enable us for the
transformation journey so as part of
that journey I'm responsible to
implement the enterprise data like
finally the capabilities are ingest
store process analyze and serve over
analytics API so primarily most of our
services that we leverage from Google
are kubernetes dataflow Google helps us
to improve our security posture I mean
it's it's a security first mindset we
have a deck of facts so Google helps us
on that and then on operation tools we
are using cloud logging and monitoring
to give us the visibility into the
systems that we are running so probably
that's in nutshell what we do and the
services and the capabilities that we
are serving are pretty much following
the container is the abstraction and
micro service architecture towards it
people you mentioned micro services you
know that's gonna pick my curiosity
please tell me how do you monitor the
health of your micro services great
question so at the beginning you know we
were working off over on Prem data
center and we didn't have container
orchestration platform as part of the
infrastructure so it was a little hard
to get a visibility into our
applications and operations was a little
bit tough and also in our pre cloud
public cloud the world-over engineering
and operations were working in silo
so our first approach was let's lift and
shift our application and then you know
progressively move to a micro service
architecture but now that we have
decided to embrace our digital
transformation with the public cloud we
are not just doing literature we are
really thinking as Rioch attacking the
application and using the bare
cloud native tools the tools that are
you know what we had in data center are
no more working out for us and we really
need a tool which gives us good observer
ability into when we are moving our
applications and workloads into public
cloud so if you don't know I mean what
we are have to observe because there's
too much newness about the public cloud
so what you end up is you can start with
four golden signals I mean as part of a
sorry best practice just take four
golden signals and then work your way
towards the SLS I mean I feel that's a
good starting point you mention decimals
tell me more a little bit about the
journey behind why you adopted a salons
and why do you think are kind of the
main benefits for Equifax to start using
a service I mean SLO has been a great
concept and one of the best practice
that I learned and it's a single
language across our engineering team
product team marketing finance sales it
helps us to talk with a common goal
right so it helps us to prioritize our
effort and once we have that kind of
single language to work across the
organization it's much better otherwise
you have a lot of meetings with analysis
paralysis you go through a chunk but you
really don't have a direction so to give
a opine ated meaning a direction SLO
helps us when it really becomes a
data-driven decisions that allows us to
figure it out where we should prioritize
our efforts and investment and also for
sre it is very important you know using
SLO as a your guiding principle when to
wake up and when to not and what really
is impacting the revenue which is
important for business so I feel that
that's pretty common theme that in
Equifax is to embrace SLO as a single
language it sounds like there are a lot
of benefits but be honest with me what
is the hardest part because this seems
too good to be true too
so those concept great but to put it in
execution is definitely definitely hard
the way I kind of articulate the SLO
engagement is really think about as the
overall meal and not the ingredients so
when your customer comes to your
restaurant they're really expecting a
meal to be served they're not really
interested in - have you got the
ingredients what was the Lord six behind
getting the all the ingredients so that
you can prepare the meal customer is
really interested in your product when
you present the product what it should
look like that is really the focus of it
and SLO helps you to measure that exact
thing what is the feeling about your
product and that is the key so it's it's
very easy to focus on the ingredient and
lose the focus on the meal so that's the
hardest part of it now what helps us to
keeping the focus is the mindset and you
need the whole organization because if
you start it's just as an engineering
project um you know you're gonna have a
lot of charm because you're not brought
your other stakeholders along with you
who has to say in your SLO so that is
the other thing you want to focus on the
mindset and frankly in Akwa facts we
started doing this and we brought Google
CRE who is the customer reliability
engineering crew helps us to execute sre
best practices in Equifax so that
engagement also helps us so looking back
this has been a journey it didn't happen
overnight is there anything that you
would have done differently knowing what
you know today well for me personally
when I took the authorial III wish I
knew i sorry much earlier I did not know
much about it so I had to do a lot of
research I had to read some books I had
to go and read do a lot of reading about
it because building a software and a
product that works at a global scale is
not easy you really need to have a
engineering mindset to an operational
problem and since my background was a
software engineering I thought yes I
think I can do a sorry so I and the
other thing I would have appreciated I
would have spend more time learning the
cloud native tools and really be
hands-on so I would feel more
comfortable but once you get
concept of SLO and working with the
engineering mindset to an operational
problem and start learning about concept
of assets I think you will not look back
I think it's a grace that's what I feel
I know there are probably a lot of
people listening in right now at the
beginning of their SLO journey and this
is a very intimidating journey and I
want to know can you give them some
advice what do you think it's it's
really important to know at the
beginning very true I mean it is
definitely hot yet I think what worked
for us probably I can say about a little
bit it's not small think about SLO
concepts in our budget concept really
learn about those concepts decide how do
you want to get started have socialized
SLO concepts within the organization
right bring your stakeholders along with
you and then figure it out a small pilot
where you would really try to implement
a critical journey on a fellow around
there once you do that I think it helps
you and Google CRE helps us to navigate
stakeholders how to present the view
around it but I would start small on it
once you have that small pilot project
with the blueprint with the some of the
best practices of SLO and arrow project
concept baked into it the next thing you
would get into is pick up the right
tools right you need the right tools to
achieve this scale of how do you
implement escalopes
frankly I mean in GCP therefore golden
signals are available out of the box so
you could literally take those four
golden signals and instrument those and
build your SLA out of it and Google has
a product Google Cloud monitoring SLO a
pilla API is to allow us to build as
follows out of those four golden signals
so we started doing that for the first
pilot it gave us a single view for our
pilot and then from that blueprint we
started replicating and moving other
services to follow the things and
iteratively we had all our services
managed through cloud monitoring and we
had a single view of all over
component to our stakeholders and it it
became a overall organizational
ecosystem that asari manages and works
when that's how I'd feel if you start
small and pick the right tools and have
cloud monitoring SLO API as your tools
behind it I think it'll help thank you
people for sharing your personal story
that was really meaningful I know there
are a lot of people listening in right
now at the beginning of their SLO
journey is there any advice that you
would give somebody that's starting that
is a long journey for the first time
definitely I think Equifax SLO has been
a journey for us
I would suggest start small really
understand the SLO and the aro project
concept because once you understand the
concept then you can decide on how to
get started
I would advise like research internally
bring your stakeholders along with you
and then started identify a small pilot
figure it out the critical journeys that
goes along with the pilot and build the
SLO surround them also get some help
from Google CRE who can help you to
navigate the SRA best practices on
building as follows so that way the
blueprint that you're building is reused
for other services once you have a pilot
identified and you have defined your
critical users yearnings which you want
to define SLO around the next topic is
really about pick the right tools that
supports that and the beauty of GCP is
they support colon signals out of the
box with Google Cloud so that makes
building the SLO as soon as possible
because you can use for golden signals
and start building your SLO once you get
into the SLO you get you can use Google
Cloud monitoring SLO API switch allows
you to put those as follows and then you
get all your SLO in a single view and I
think with those two point I feel it's a
great start
thank you so much people for taking the
time to talk to me today and for sharing
such a meaningful story of your SLO
adoption and equifax
thank you it's pleasure so next let's
let's take one example let's
think about SLO monitoring for your
Jeannie fleet and what I want us to take
a step back is to understand that the
SLO monitoring functionality really does
not depend on the underlying
infrastructure that you are deployed so
within Google Cloud we have
out-of-the-box integration for every
single platform available so if you're
using G key or compute engine or App
Engine or any other DCP product you'll
be able to create a Salons in that
environment we have built curated
out-of-the-box experience for the antis
product as well however if you are have
a multi cloud deployment of running
on-premise environments as well if
you're bringing in your metrics into the
backend of cloud monitoring we will be
able to create and help you set up your
solos with our API very easily on those
environments as well even if they are
kubernetes or virtual machines or other
clouds and when we talk about scale SLO
monitoring is really built on the scale
of the entire GCE
console back end for most monitoring and
logging this is the same back-end that
operates internal Google as well and our
SLO API is currently used internally at
Google but it's also used by our
external cloud customers everything gets
built with zero config from day one and
it gives you all of the observability so
there are a lot of the golden signal
that we pulled mentioned there are a lot
of metrics that come in out of the box
and get added to the product for you to
be able to create your cells very easily
all of the functionality that we are
talking about in terms of SLO monitoring
at scale both the UI and API
they are in general availability as of
today so really happy to make this
functionality available to one of our
customers and in order to showcase the
UI experience
Patrick Eaton the engineering lead
has helped build the UI nd API for SLO
monitoring is gonna give us a whirlwind
tour of how to do SLO monitoring for
your gk environment
take it away Patrick hello today I would
like to introduce you to this
service-oriented monitoring and SLO
monitoring features in GCPs cloud
monitoring product these features are
currently in general availability first
I want to draw your attention to the
workspace selector in the upper left a
workspace is a concept that allows one
to combine multiple projects into a
single view this is great for being able
to view an entire fleet of services in a
single pane of glass next notice that
we're in the monitoring menu and the
services submenu of the cloud console
the first view you'll see in the
services area is the service inventory
or services overview page on this page
we see a list of all of the micro
services that have been detected or
identified by the user you can see that
there's a number of different types of
services that depends on the on the
technology that's used to develop those
services we currently support ji-ae
Cloud endpoints SDM gke and those
service Mash and what we're going to
focus on today gke based micro services
in order to understand these more let's
start by defining a gke micro service
when we click define service we see that
the tray slides out with a list of all
of the gke entities that are in the work
space including deployments replica sets
kubernetes services namespaces and so on
depending on the model that your
organization uses any of these entities
could be a micro service now I know that
the way that my organization works
deployments are
correspond to microservices and i also
know from discussions with my with my
broader organization including PM and
Inge and operations that the ad service
is a service that requires particular
attention so we search for ad service
and find out there's actually two of
them running in our workspace we'll
select one of them give them a name
click Submit and with that we've created
the first gke based micro service next
you can read more about best practices
for monitoring services at the
documentation link here or you can move
directly to creating a service level
objective instead we're going to go back
to the inventory and notice that our new
micro service appears in the inventory
already it includes the metadata labels
that are used to define the micro
service including the project the
cluster name CSM demo and the deployment
ad service it also indicates that we
don't have any SLS or SLO based alerts
yet if we click into the dashboard for
the service itself at the top of that we
see that the first piece of monitoring
data is about SLO s this is granted
space at the top of the page because SLO
is our one of the most valuable things
for monitoring services now we don't yet
have any SLO s so let's fix that by
creating an SLO again this describes the
service that we're creating the Esso
alert for some service types have
default availability or latency metrics
but we're going to pick our own metric
now there are a number of metrics that
are available out of the box for all
users to define s loz for example here's
a list of container metrics that may be
useful for defining SLO s GC elby's also
have a number of metrics which can be
useful
as the developer of this app however I
know that the thing that best reflects
the performance of the ad service is the
response latency metric based on
discussions with p.m. and others I know
that customers are satisfied with the ad
service when it responds in 30
milliseconds or less on any of the
containers that are running that image
once we describe the metric that we're
going to use to evaluate the SLO we can
see a preview of how that metric is
actually performing and we can also
guess that 30 milliseconds is actually a
pretty aggressive target given the
behavior of the system right now to
finish defining the SLO we set the
compliance period to be a calendar week
and a performance goal of 90% what that
means is that 90% of all requests to the
ad service need to finish in 30
milliseconds in order to be compliant
finally we give it a name we click
Submit and now we've created our first
SLO we can evaluate the SLO based on the
historical behavior of the system so we
don't have to wait for history to
accumulate we can see that right now the
service level indicator the metric is
running at about 95% which is greater
than our 90% target we can also see that
about half of the error budget is
remaining for the week if we expand the
time selector out to a week we can see
that indeed at the beginning of the week
the error budget resets and then trails
off towards thee as the week progresses
based on last week it looks like we will
run out of air budget so there's
probably some reliability work that
needs to be done for this service notice
also that there is a view to look at
alerts SLO based alerts that are firing
for this service in order to create
these you can use this link here and
alert can be created right in context
the SLO based alerts are based on the
concept of a fast burn alert which means
that the system can detect when the
error budget is being burned at a rate
that's not sustainable and such that the
system can remain in compliance if we
look at other parts of the service
dashboard we can see that the metrics
widget is interesting it contains a lot
of the out-of-the-box metrics that are
available to users arranged in a number
of bundles it's currently seen the
container metrics corresponding to CPU
we can also look at for example pod
level metrics on network usage we select
that and the the charts update we can
see individual pods and the network
usage on those alternatively we could
look at a look at a node metric such as
CPU to see what kind of capacity our
cluster has if we scroll down further we
can see the pods the kubernetes pods
that make up this service here we see we
have five pods running the add service
right now all of them are ready and
running so they're healthy for each of
them resource utilization is described
and under the Snowman we see a link to
the kubernetes engine page if we switch
to the kubernetes part of the cloud
console this is where we can see more
information about the pod including its
events its logs and also take actions on
the pods such as restarting it the last
part of the service dashboard is the
logs widget this widget gives a brief
overview of the logs that are being
emitted by the micro service if however
we want to look at the logs in more
detail we can go to the logs viewer now
the interesting thing about pivoting to
the logs viewer is that the context or
the filter state for the micro service
is preserved you can see here that the
filter by default goes to the cluster
that were
we've been monitoring and the ad service
even the time stamp filter is brought up
brought across to the logs viewer to
preserve context the logs viewer shows a
histogram of blog volume
it also facets it by severity we can
filter two errors to the error severity
and very quickly get to the stack traces
corresponding to our microservice now
let's return to the idea of SLO based
alerts if we go to the overview we can
see that there are three SLO based
alerts that are current currently firing
if we filter to those services we see
that one of them is the default gke
namespace let's look at what a service
level dashboard looks like when there
are incidents firing the thing you'll
notice different is that now there is an
alert timeline at the top the timeline
indicates when incidents are firing by
the red bars on the timeline if you
hover on these bars you see a summary of
the corresponding alert along with a
link to get the alert details the the
event timeline can also be the the alert
timeline can also be used as a time
selector and when you select the time
there that also updates the time for all
the charts and for all the log entries
you should also notice that this default
micro service has two SLO s defined
so you can have more than one SLO
defined for a single service you can
also have more than one alert defined
for a single SLO that completes a tour
of the UI for a service-oriented
monitoring and SLO s you should note
that if you're interested in managing
large numbers of services or SLO s there
is an API that's also available that
allows access to all of these features
it has been my pleasure to introduce you
to service-oriented monitoring concepts
today in cloud monitoring thank you
thank you so much Patrick for the
insightful demo I really appreciate the
work that went into building the product
and putting the demo together I will not
share also special thanks to the equifax
team that has been one of elite users of
SLO monitoring and many other tcp
customers that are already using this
product in production today I want to
also thank the CRE team that cloud
reliability engineering team at Google
for using the SLO monitoring product as
a best practice for adopting asari best
practices to our organizations I'm
really happy that the product is finally
in general availability and please give
it a try if you want to learn more about
other called operation sessions and
learn about all of the work that we're
doing on cloud monitoring and cloud
logging these are the available talks
thank you so much for your time